(crowd cheering)
- All right, y'all, let's close things out
with something I hope will
add some joy to your day.
This is what I'm liking.
(upbeat music)
(audience cheering)
There's something totally rewarding
in lending help when
someone needs it most.
An Ontario woman knows that all too well.
After meeting a homeless man
in her neighborhood earlier
this year, she decided
to offer him work on her farm
but she didn't stop there.
Now, not only does he have a roof
over his head,
they both say their lives
are changed forever.
We have them on the line
right now watching on Citytv.
Everybody, give a big hello
to Danielle and Brian.
(audience cheering and applauding)
What's up, y'all?
Oh my God, I wanna be where
you are, I love animals.
So Danielle, as soon
as you learned Brian's
story, you took action.
Can you tell everybody how you did that?
- Yes, so for weeks, I
had seen Brian sitting
outside our local drugstore,
collecting change.
And I decided one day
that I needed to stop and
talk to him, and I did.
And once I learned his story, I knew
that I needed to offer
him a job on my farm.
So that, I did.
And then I decided that, you know what?
He needed a haircut and we went
and took him for a haircut.
Since then, Brian's just
really, really changed
and grown as a person.
- Man, Brian, I mean,
that had to mean the world
to you that somebody took
the time not only to stop
and talk to you, have
an actual conversation
but then offer you a
job, what was that like?
- It was amazing.
It was wonderful and
I couldn't believe it.
She helped me out greatly
and it was very nice
to have someone to stop
and actually, talk to me
and to see what I'd like about life.
- Yeah, absolutely.
Well, Danielle,
Brian's also found
housing, correct, right?
- Yes, so that's right.
One night, it was going to be
minus 20 degrees where we live
and I just couldn't bring
myself to drop him off
at his uninsulated shed
where he was living.
So I did a post
on Facebook, asking our
community if they'd be willing
to donate $5 to help Brian
get a room for the night.
And our community was
absolutely incredible
and came up with enough
money, not only for one night,
but for nine nights in a hotel room.
And then I started a GoFundMe,
which has now reached $11,000
and Brian now has a room in a house.
- Oh, that's incredible.
(audience applauding)
That's incredible.
'Cause, you know what?
People wanna help, Danielle,
and they don't know how, always.
And Brian, way to go, man.
Congratulations on turning life around.
Thank you so much, Brian.
(audience applauding)
Thank you, Danielle.
I'm liking your post right now.
- [Brian] I appreciate all the help.
(audience cheering and applauding)
- Well that's not all.
Our season-long partner, Pilot Pen, makers
of G2, the go-to pen of the
Kelly Clarkson Show, want
to honor truly unstoppable
people just like y'all.
So they're gonna write
you a check for $1,000.
How's that sound?
(audience cheering)
- That's too cool.
- All right, y'all, have
a blessed afternoon!
Everybody, before we go,
the 149th Kentucky Derby airs tomorrow,
Saturday, May 6th and coverage
begins at noon, Eastern.
Check it out on NBC and Peacock.
Thank you to all our guests today,
Ryan Seacrest, Taylor
Hicks, India Amarteifio,
Corey Mylchreest, Arsema Thomas and Maya.
Y'all have a great day,
and if it's not great, try and change it.